So this is this address translation, and
what you can access in
memory is really powerful.
This is how we're going to be
able to protect the data and
code of a given process.
And the way we're going to be able
to do it is, the operating system,
I said is responsible for managing
those page tables you're talking about.
Remember you always
start a virtual address.
So process is going to
start with virtual address,
which has to be translated to
physical address that should fall
in a physical page that we're
talking about, physical frame.
So the operating system will not
map a virtual page of a process A,
but remember you're going to
start with a virtual address that
has a virtual page number and
displacement within that.
It will not map a virtual page
of process A to a physical
page that has been given to process B.
Remember these pages
are reusable resources or
time to get assigned to
different processes so
that currently a certain physical
page has been assigned to process B.
The operating system is not going to
set up the page table of process A,
such that a page table entry in
that process A's page table,
can point to the space
that belongs to B.
That's our protection isolation
whatever you call it.
We have essentially partitioned
the physical memory that we have,
among the different processes
we have in the system.
And we limit these processes
to only the portion of memory they
have access toward a given time.
By making sure that they can only reach
those portions through their phase
tables, and
the operating system is again going
to manage their phase tables.
The trusted computing base
you trusted to do this right,
so we keep a different processes
separate from each other.
Which is what results in getting
protected from each other and
process A doesn't trust process B.
So as I explained process A cannot
access process B's memory
because it has no way to read
the memory that belongs to process B.
This will work as long as this
page table is correctly managed.
And as I said before they're managed by
the operating system which is trusted so
let's hope they are correctly managed
unless somebody finds a way to attack
and successfully compromise
the operating system.